the challenge to electric car makers is
make cars people want to buy without
subsidy we didn't move from the horse
and cart to the internal combustion
engine on government regulations and
subsidy we moved because the car was a
better product and if the electric car
is a better product people will buy it
and that may help to get to Net Zero at
the moment it isn't a better product the
petrol engine is a far superior more
convenient product and so I think it
needs the technology to come through
first rather than doing it by regulation
by dictat by bossiness because voters
won't ultimately put up with it and nor
should they because ultimately people
will not vote and nor should they vote
to be cold and
poor